conor mcgregor you spent a hundred
thousand dollars
on a sleepy mcgregor chain he did lose
it is pretty funny he lost his last
fight where do you guys
stand i feel like you get asked about
this a lot he really gets asked about
this a lot
will you guys ever fight we'll see what
happens right now he needs me more than
i need him
he's one in three in the past five years
so he seems to be on this downward
spiral
while the fight you know could make
sense between us i don't want to fight
someone who just keeps on losing keep on
losing keep on losing
so uh we'll see what ends up happening
i would love to knock that irish [ __ ]
out for sure
quote of the day would you ever want to
fight your brother your brother's also a
fighter could we ever see a paul brother
match up
it depends what day you ask some days
we're like mad at each other
and want to beat each other up but
everything's been smooth sailing
and we're closer than ever so i don't
know if that fight will ever happen
the glitch klitschko's weren't able to
fight each other our parents don't want
it to happen
so okay who knows